for those of you that didn't notice
Florida was doing great long before
Rhonda Sanctus got there I can't deal
with the the Sanctus thing I can't tell
if Des Sanctus is that Trump messed up
saying to sanctimonious once and so now
he's he's sticking with the Sanctus but
the serious use of that is crazy people
are fleeing from New York to Florida and
other places right because of high taxes
and out of control crime it's really bad
yeah not because of the governor thank
you Mr President for doing that but it's
not because of the governor Florida was
doing fantastically you had a governor
named Rick Scott who did a very good job
even Charlie Chris the Democrat did a
good job and he had very good numbers
sunshine and ocean are very alluring
it's not too hard to work it's like a
travel video promo